[Música]
cara carmina ilustradora y autor es
fácil bienvenida a radio canadá
internacional cada hora pablo cómo
estarás muchas gracias la invitación
pues muchas gracias a ti por haberla
aceptado querida cara cada vamos a
hablar hoy de tu último libro que acaba
de salir en la librería y se llama autor
theodor que yo tengo por acá tengo una
copia de sí de theodore es el conejo que
el conejo con lente lo podemos llamar
así
acá lo tengo yo también delante
tenemos que decirles a nuestros
televidentes si podemos llamarlos así oa
las personas que nos están viendo en
este momento que ese libro está escrito
en frases exactamente y es el segundo
libro de una serie que sale con mi texto
con mis ilustraciones que se llama de la
pan mala en español sería como los
conejos traviesos
es con la casa de edición el lema la
edición y mala
aquí en quebec por eso es en francés ya
y decíamos cara que está ya en la
librería explícanos por favor háblanos
de theodore quien es todo bueno pero es
un conejito que es muy inteligente le
gusta mucho las matemáticas su hobby es
hacer origami es amigo de pau link que
es la coneja de mi primer libro de esta
serie y él tiene un gran problema que
como es tan inteligente y usa lentes
todos los chicos en la escuela los otros
conejitos se burlan de él mi serie de
los conejos es una serie que toca el
tema del bullying de la intimidación en
las escuelas y cada personaje de cada
libro va a tener una problemática
particular y son víctimas del bullying
en este caso teodoro es víctima del
bullying porque es un conejito muy
inteligente es muy nerd como decimos en
inglés no y como muy intelectual y bueno
los lentes a veces no le ayudan en los
niños a veces molestan a los otros niños
por cosas físicas en este caso
l tiene esa situación
y el deudor tiene esa situación no le
complica la vida y el hecho es miren en
la escuela puedes hacer que esté siempre
triste y habla con su padre de ella
claro claro en la historia es un tema
que me gusta abarcar cómo se aproxima un
niño a los adultos para tocar el tema
del bullying que no siempre es sencillo
sobre todo cuando los chiquito y en el
libro theodor justamente él tiene esa
problemática que no quiere causar
problemas él lo molestan tres conejos en
específico le quitan sus cosas hay una
pequeña altercación chiquita y él no
sabe si contarle a sus papás o no porque
pues le da miedo no y uno a veces no
sabe qué hacer y acaba teniendo el
confidente a un conejo que es como el
que limpia la escuela que es un conejo
ya viejito como que quiere mucho a los
conejitos de la escuela y al final él
termina resolviendo esta problemática
gracias a los consejos que este conejo
le da
bueno muy interesante y ahora ya
theodore está en las librerías pero con
el problema de la cob y cómo se puede
acceder cómo se puede comprar en línea
sí bueno mira estamos contentísimos
porque mi casa de publicaciones tiene de
servicio de librería todo quebec e
internacional también entonces
quienquiera que quiera comprar el libro
y no pueden una librería ya sea aquí en
quebec en canadá en eeuu méxico etcétera
pueden accesar al sitio mente mi casa
publicaciones lema la punto sea
y podemos pasar el index puesto yo lo
puedo subir a mi sitio web también en mi
sitio web cara carmina puntocom está el
sitio de mi mesón de edición y ahí
pueden comprar el libro en línea pero
bueno con el móvil y toda esta
emergencia sanitaria las librerías en
quebec y fueron abriendo poco a poco y
ahorita estamos muy contentos porque ya
abrieron en todo que ve que incluido
montreal así que pueden ir a la librería
ya está en todas las librerías de quebec
muy contento
que preguntaba eso cara porque estuve
leyendo un artículo muy curioso este fin
de semana en el que una mujer una señora
que tiene que vender café en línea se
quejaba porque por una libra de café que
lleva vende por 14 o 15 dólares tienes
que pagarle a post seca nada a correos
de canadá 13 dólares con 25 para que se
juegue entonces como que no funciona eso
eso sé por eso te preguntaba cómo
funcionan para los libros
bueno con los libros es un poquito
diferente me parece que el delivery
quebec no es nada caro no tengo
exactamente la cifra pero si lo compran
en quebec el libro consta alrededor de
16 17 dólares y el envío no creo que
pase de 20 dólares con el precio del
libro y así es un envío internacional de
tus variabilidad por el país
bueno y ya hay un tercer libro también
que está en camino
de la misma serie exactamente y se llama
rosita pero les voy a guardar lo que
sigue el título porque si no como reveló
mucho pero el personaje principal se
llama rosita y es la prima mexicana de
pauline que viene a visitar la que ve
que es una conejita muy simpática y
llega justo en una época que a los niños
les gusta mucho acá que es el halloween
pero rossi está como en mexicana ella no
celebran halloween ella ya celebra el
día de muertos entonces por ahí va a
haber una situación donde vamos a tocar
las dos celebraciones y para mí es un
placer ilustrar eso es una historia
original mía también tocamos el tema de
la intimidación de nuevo ahora nos
aproximamos al miedo como los niños
manejan el miedo y como todos tenemos
miedo de algo y bueno es la primicia
sale en septiembre y esperemos que para
ese entonces podamos reunirnos un
poquito más con esto del comedia a lo
mejor hacemos una presentación del libro
estás invitado por supuesto
muchísimas gracias muchísimas gracias la
pregunta que me viene a la mente de una
forma espontánea a cara ojos que estos
libros están escritos en frases
originalmente
para los que nos están escuchando en
latinoamérica por ejemplo o en cualquier
país hispanófono hay que decirles que no
están todavía en español piensa de
alguna forma traducirlo claro a mí me
encantaría es un proceso bien complejo
el la compraventa de derechos de un
libro cuando es una editorial a otra
meditar ya les francesa que ve acá
entonces ellos no tienen esa esa
capacidad de hacer libros en español
porque no es un mercado entonces ahora
con el comida es otra cosa que el mundo
editorial un poquito estamos sufriendo
porque venía la época de ferias
literarias en todo el mundo la más
grande la de bolonia que es para libros
infantiles se canceló está la de
frankfurt la de parís y es en esas
ferias donde las casas de publicación se
juntan y
e intercambian catálogos infantiles para
ver qué libros se pueden ir a otros
países y entonces bueno ahora me mi casa
publicación está haciendo todo lo
posible virtualmente para contactar a
otras casas de publicación en este caso
es hispanas queremos abarcar el mercado
también anglófono entonces bueno es
cuestión de tiempo de esperar y ver cómo
pasan las cosas con el cob y ojalá que
se pueda porque a mí me encantaría tener
unos libros en español mi lengua materna
soy mexicana y sabes que a mí méxico me
hace mucha falta y nada me haría más
feliz
bueno ya que estás abordando el tema de
covite 19 cara y que estamos todos en
cuarentena por acá por este país aunque
ya está la cuarentena más o menos que
levantándose progresivamente y tú eres
una artista multifacética y entre además
de ilustrar los libros y como teodorín y
los conejos maliciosos también tienes lo
que tú llamas
foto intervenciones creo
y que me parecen muy interesantes cómo
surgió la idea de hacer esas fotos
intervenciones y quizás explicar antes
que qué es una foto intervención para
que la gente tenga una idea claro mira
esto es un estilo de arte que en inglés
se llama foto intervención a lo mejor en
español tiene otro nombre entre venir
fotos es una especie de collage donde el
artista retoma una fotografía de alguien
más o de él mismo y trabaja con ella se
puede trabajar pintando se puede
trabajar con ella bordando se pueden
hacer muchas cosas es una especie de
collage donde el fondo principal es una
fotografía a mí me gusta mucho la
fotografía vieja en blanco y negro y
bueno en algún momento de mi vida he
tomado fotos siempre tengo fotos en mi
instagram es una es una parte de
artística mía que me gusta pero no soy
fotógrafo integre mi trabajo de
ilustración en fotografía hace tiempo
hace unos años en 2014 disculpa cuando
empecé a ser escritor
yo quise empezar a ser artista de la
calle aquí encontrará hay mucho arte de
la arte de la calle hay muralismo
esto es un festival incluso de mural
exacto exacto hay un festival de murales
y en este tiempo que ahora está
cancelado por el comido nos juntamos
todos los artistas de la de la calle a
hacer nuestras intervenciones ya sea el
muralismo o de pegarnos pero trabajo en
la calle y ese es el que me gusta bien
iglesia mate está no tengo bien el dato
de cómo se llame en españa lo máximo que
es cómo pegar tu trabajo se hace con un
pegamento que hacemos con harina no we
page y así empezaron mis fotos
interventions entonces yo ahora con el
hobbit tenía la necesidad de expresarme
artísticamente y tener algo que decir
acerca de lo que yo creo que es
importante y para mí me ha tocado mucho
el tema de las enfermeras de los
trabajadores de la salud todo lo que han
hecho y todo el tiempo que han tomado y
todos los esfuerzos que hacen personales
y laborales para
para hacer todo lo que han hecho y el
sitio de una serie de 5 imágenes que
hablan de lo importante que es para mí
el decirles gracias a ellos y en un
punto muy particular que toca a montreal
ya que ve como sabes el comido ha tocado
mucho los ancianos en las casas de
ancianos ha sido donde más hemos tenido
nuestros excesos y la problemática
sanitaria entonces hay una parte de
estas fotos que hablan que promueven el
quedarse en casa por nuestros enfermos o
sabes por nuestros ancianos y las he
estado pegando ahora en montreal comencé
hace unas semanas y poco a poco iré
poniendo más y más y más
ya por curiosidad cara me imagino que si
son
fotos que vas a pegar en las calles
tiene que ser como de un material que no
se desintegre con él por estar expuesto
al exterior por estar en la calle con la
lluvia el sol y todo esto bueno mira la
calle el arte de la calle es muy efímero
y todos los artistas solaris lo sabemos
entonces en los que pegamos usamos un
papel muy delgadito tiene que ser muy
muy delgadito para que pueda pegarse en
muchas superficies y al final estamos
conscientes de que eso no va a durar yo
tengo trabajo que hice en 2000 porque he
hecho arte de la calle en italia y en
montreal y a la fecha me llegan de
repente fotos anís tram de gente que
toma fotos todavía después de 34 años de
mi trabajo en roma' que sigue pegados en
las paredes ya mí eso me impresiona
porque la mayoría entonces ya no está la
gente lo quita hay gente que los
colecciona hay gente que los limpia y es
como muy efímero entonces eso realidad
es algo que lo sabemos
entonces esa esa variable hay que
tenerla en cuenta
pero igual ahora podríamos podríamos
hablar muchísimo pero yo creo que vamos
a tener la ocasión de regresar en otra
ocasión para que hablemos sobre tus
las ocupaciones artísticas que además
son muy importantes y muy interesantes
te gustaría agregar algo en particular a
determinar esta entrevista bueno me
gustaría tal vez enseñarle a la gente el
primer libro de la colección de polino
y el segundo de theodore que son los que
ya están a la venta en librerías son mis
dos bebés con mi historia y con mis
ilustraciones están disponibles edición
lema la punto sea
y en todas las librerías de quebec y
muchas gracias a ti ya radio canadá por
darme siempre la oportunidad de venir a
mostrarles mi trabajo muchas gracias y
bueno gracias a ti cara por haber
aceptado esta entrevista con radio canal
internacional hasta la próxima gracias
[Música]